Anthropic ist zurück mit einem
bahnbrechenden neuen Modell: Claude
Opus 5.5, dem ersten Modell der neuen
Claude 5.5-Familie. Und mein Gott,
dieses Modell ist wirklich unglaublich.
Es ist ein bedeutender Fortschritt
gegenüber Opus 5, besonders bei
agentischem Programmieren,
Computernutzung und Wissensarbeit,
während es auf dem Niveau von Claude
Fable 5.1 agiert. Sie haben richtig
gehört, Claude Fable 5.1 bei den
meisten Aufgaben und dabei 40%
günstiger im Betrieb als Opus 5.
Erinnern Sie sich, wie all diese
KI-Labore davon sprachen, das Tempo an
der technologischen Front zu drosseln?
Nun, Opus 5.5 ist das erste Modell von
Anthropic, das seit dieser Ankündigung
veröffentlicht wurde. Wie frühere
Versionen wurde es vor der Einführung
von externen Gutachtern getestet,
darunter Meter sowie Frontier Design.
Anthropic gibt zudem an, dass dies ihre
bisher umfassendste
Alignment-Evaluierung ist, und Opus 5.5
erzielte dabei sein bisher stärkstes
Ergebnis. Wie bereits erwähnt,
arbeitet Opus 5.5 auf dem Niveau von
Fable 5.1, ist dabei aber etwa 30%
schneller und 40%günstiger pro Aufgabe
als Opus 5. Für Claude Code führt
Anthropic ebenfalls ein großes Upgrade
durch. Die 5-Stunden-Sitzungslimits
werden um 20%erhöht, und das liegt
daran, dass Opus 5.5 kostengünstiger
ist. Sie können innerhalb dieser
Grenzen etwa 25%mehr Nutzung
herausholen. Ein weiterer Punkt ist,
dass Plus-, Pro-, Max-und Team-Nutzer
einen Reset erhalten, den sie jederzeit
verwenden können, was den Nutzern mit
diesem neueren Modell wesentlich mehr
Flexibilität bietet. Leute, tut mir
wirklich leid, dass ich das Video
unterbreche, aber es würde mir sehr
viel bedeuten, wenn ihr dieses Video
liken, den Kanal abonnieren und die
Glocke aktivieren könntet, da viele
von euch noch nicht abonniert haben. Es
hilft mir wirklich sehr, mehr Videos zu
machen und euch bessere Inhalte zu
liefern. Auf der „World of AI“-
Benchmark-und Vibe-Coding-Plattform
haben wir es bereits in mehreren
Bereichen bewertet und sind zu dem
Schluss gekommen, dass dies das derzeit
am besten bewertete Modell auf dem
Markt ist, sogar vor Astra, was
irgendwie wahnsinnig ist, Leute. Hier
glänzt Opus 5.5 in verschiedenen
Disziplinen wie agentischem Handeln,
Schlussfolgerung und Debugging,
während es gleichzeitig in vielen
anderen Bereichen neue Maßstäbe setzt
. Und wenn Sie Ihr eigenes Modell sowie
Ihren eigenen Endpunkt bewerten
möchten, um ein besseres Gefühl
dafür zu bekommen, wie Sie diese
Modelle nutzen können, empfehle ich
dringend, den „World of AI“-
Benchmark auszuprobieren. Dies ist ein
Tool, mit dem Sie sogar komplett
kostenlos starten können. Was die
Leistung angeht, ist Opus 5.5 ein
bedeutendes Upgrade gegenüber Opus 5.
Doch hier haben sie das Modell in
verschiedenen Bereichen getestet, und
beim agentischen Programmieren mit
Terminal Bench 4.0 übertrifft es
sowohl Fable 5.1 als auch GPT-6 Astral
–und das mit einem ziemlich
beachtlichen Vorsprung, was irgendwie
verrückt ist. Beim Cursor Bench GDP
Eval setzt es neue Maßstäbe und
erreicht bei diesen Benchmark-Werten
Höchstwerte im Vergleich zu anderen
führenden Modellen. Sogar bei Dingen
wie OSWorld, also der Computernutzung,
schneidet es im Vergleich zu den
anderen Modellen ziemlich gut ab, was
wirklich schön zu sehen ist. Mir ist
im Blogbeitrag aufgefallen, dass eine
Aufgabe damit eine Code-Migration von
680.000 Zeilen in unter einem Tag
bewältigte–eine Arbeit, die
normalerweise Wochen dauern würde. Es
optimierte 39 von 40 Webseiten ohne
Funktionsverlust und übertraf andere
Claude-Modelle beim Erstellen eines
ausgereiften Spiels durch einen
einzigen Prompt, was zeigt, dass dies
ein echtes Allround-Modell ist, das in
vielen Bereichen glänzt. Ich habe auch
gesehen, dass Claude Opus 5.5 auf dem
Index von Artificial Analysis den
ersten Platz bei diesem Benchmark
belegt, bei gleichzeitig 20%
Preissenkung und einem höheren
Cache-Hit-Rabatt. Und wo Opus 5.5
wirklich herausragt, ist seine
Effizienz. Es kostet weniger pro Token
und verbraucht weniger Token pro
Aufgabe, was zu etwa 40%niedrigeren
Token-Kosten führt als bei Opus 5. Es
gibt auch einen Schnellmodus in Claude
Code und auf der Claude-Plattform, der
bis zu 2,5-mal höhere
Geschwindigkeiten bietet und 8 $ pro 1
Million Input-Token sowie 40 $ pro 1
Million Output-Token kostet. Die
allgemeine Preisgestaltung für Opus
5.5 im Standardmodus liegt bei 4 $ pro
1 Million Input-Token–was viel
günstiger ist als zuvor–und 20 $ pro
1 Million Output-Token. Etwas, das mir
außerdem aufgefallen ist: Das Modell
ist sehr token-intensiv, was bedeutet,
dass es nicht ganz so token-effizient
ist, wie es scheint. Es verbraucht
tatsächlich eine ganze Menge an Token.
Behalten Sie das also im Hinterkopf.
Wenn Sie die besten KI-Tools, Workflows
und Neuigkeiten vor allen anderen
erhalten möchten, abonnieren Sie
meinen kostenlosen Newsletter über den
Link in der Beschreibung unten, der
absolut kostenlos ist. Wenn Sie jetzt
mit diesem Modell loslegen möchten,
können Sie das ganz einfach über den
Claude-Chatbot tun oder auch über
deren API-Plattform darauf zugreifen.
Und wenn Sie es nutzen und testen sowie
unser Coding-Harness verwenden möchten
, das selbst ein großartiges Tool ist,
können Sie es über die Links in der
Beschreibung unten ausprobieren. Und
das ist eine großartige Möglichkeit
für dich, es auszuprobieren und mit
diesem Modell loszulegen. Bei der
Spieleentwicklung konnte Opus 5.5 in
einem einzigen Durchlauf ein komplettes
Spiel im Mario Kart-Stil erstellen, und
das Ergebnis sieht deutlich besser aus
als bei Fable 5.1. Dies wurde von
Bridge Bench durchgeführt und ist
wirklich wahnsinnig, denn die Liebe zum
Detail ist beeindruckend. Es hat die
bekannten Charaktere Mario und Luigi
erschaffen, die tatsächlich spielbar
sind, aber es ist verrückt, weil man
alle Komponenten dieses Klons hat, wie
den Geschwindigkeits-Boost und die
verschiedenen Extras, die man auf der
Karte einsammeln kann. Und das ist
tatsächlich viel besser als das, was
ich bei Fable 5.1 mit genau demselben
Prompt gesehen habe, da Fable 5.1
Schwierigkeiten hatte, denselben Test
in der gleichen Qualität wie Opus 5.1
durchzuführen. Dies ist zweifellos
eine der beeindruckendsten Coding-Demos
, die ich je von einem KI-Modell
gesehen habe. Und siehst du das hier?
Dies ist eine vollständige Simulation
des Launch-Videos für Claude Opus 5.5.
Aber wir haben eine komplette Kopie
davon, die tatsächlich von Opus 5.5
programmiert wurde, was ich mir
wirklich nicht hätte vorstellen
können. Hier hat jemand den
ursprünglichen Tweet genommen und das
Modell angewiesen, ihn ohne externe
Musik, Sounds, Bilddateien oder
ähnliches nachzuprogrammieren. Das ist
alles vollständig von Grund auf neu
programmiert worden. Das ist einfach
wahnsinnig, denn man hat dieses
komplette Video, das von Opus 5.5
programmiert wurde und das Launch-Video
selbst nachahmt. Soweit ich das
beurteilen kann, ist dies ein Modell,
das sich hervorragend für die
Erstellung von Videos und Animationen
eignet. Die Entwicklung ist
offensichtlich etwas, das Anthropic
perfektioniert hat, aber dies ist der
nächste Bereich, in dem diese Modelle
meiner Meinung nach ihre Dominanz
ausbauen. Hier hat es dieses Mosaik mit
13.000 einzelnen Kacheln vollständig
programmiert. Dies wurde komplett von
Opus 5.5 durch Code gezeichnet und
animiert, ohne dass ein einziges Bild
verwendet wurde. Es ist ziemlich
verrückt, dass es in der Lage ist,
eine solche Aufgabe mit seinen
kreativen Programmierfähigkeiten zu
bewältigen. Und nur um dir einen
Anhaltspunkt dafür zu geben, wie viel
besser Opus 1.5 im Vergleich zu GPT-6
Astra ist: Hier erhielten beide den
gleichen Prompt, um ein autonomes
Waymo-Fahrzeug in 3GS zu erstellen. Und
ja, Opus 1.5 sieht hier wirklich
beeindruckend aus, denn der Detailgrad
und die allgemeine Ausführung zeigen,
dass diese Version im Vergleich zu
Astra die wahre Größe zeigt. Es hat
die Physik, die Gesamtabmessungen sowie
die Shader dieser Generation im
Vergleich zum Astra-Modell perfekt
getroffen. Und man kann sehen, dass es
bei den Lidar-Kameras sowie den
Sensoren großartige Arbeit geleistet
hat. Und es hat alle Komponenten, die
wir beim echten Auto sehen, präzise
generiert. Und es fügt diesen
Detailgrad hinzu, den man bei GPT-6
Astra nicht wirklich sehen würde. Dies
hier ist eine SUV-Generation der
Nintendo Switch. Und das ist kein Bild
oder Video, das tatsächlich von
Nintendo ausgegeben wurde. Dies ist
etwas, das von Opus 5.5 mit maximalem
Reasoning ausgegeben wurde. Aber das
Verrückte ist, Leute, dass es bei
dieser Generation 20%oder 27%des
Sitzungslimits eines 20-Dollar-Plans
verbraucht hat. Daher ist es manchmal
vielleicht nicht das Beste, dieses
Modell als tägliches Arbeitsgerät zu
verwenden. Vielleicht sollte man es bei
komplexen Projekten auf maximales
Reasoning einstellen. Aber für
einfachere Aufgaben kann man zu Haiku
oder–Entschuldigung, nicht Haiku,
sondern Sonnet–wechseln. Und wo wir
gerade von Haiku sprechen: Sie
versuchen tatsächlich, es bald
zurückzubringen. Wir werden also
vielleicht in den nächsten paar Wochen
ein Haiku 5.5-Modell bekommen. Als
Nächstes hat Opus 5.5 diesen
vollständigen Minecraft-Klon erstellt.
Und das ist das erste Mal, dass ich die
Möglichkeit habe, bestimmte Dinge wie
den Ton anzupassen. Ich werde den Ton
tatsächlich einschalten, weil ich
bereits weiß, dass es meine Ohrhörer
zerstören wird, wenn ich einen Block
zerbreche, aber es ist etwas, das einem
diese Flexibilität gibt, all diese
verschiedenen Einstellungen anzupassen,
wie die Wolken sowie ein paar andere
Dinge wie Helligkeit, Sichtfeld, und
ich kann tatsächlich eine neue Welt
erstellen, und wir können weitermachen
und uns das tatsächlich ansehen. Hört
mal rein, Leute. Es hat Soundeffekte
hinzugefügt. Bevor ich mich in diese
Demo stürze, möchte ich die
Soundeffekte einschalten, weil ich
weiß, dass es mein Ohr zerstört, wenn
ich diesen Block zerbreche. Okay, wir
sind zurück, und das ist einfach
wahnsinnig, Leute. Das ist definitiv
der beste Minecraft-Klon, den ich je
gesehen habe, was die Visualisierung
der vollständigen Textur des
Sandbox-Spiels angeht. Es hat auch
mehrere Mobs hinzugefügt. Man kann
sehen, dass es sogar Soundeffekte gibt,
wenn man diese verschiedenen Mobs
trifft, und es hat nicht nur einen Mob
hinzugefügt, sondern gleich mehrere
wie Schafe sowie Kühe, und dann hat
man sogar all die verschiedenen
Funktionen wie im ursprünglichen
Sandbox-Spiel. Das zeigt also nur, wie
intelligent und wie unglaublich dieses
Modell ist. Jetzt gibt es sogar ein
Inventarsystem. Wenn ich also einen
Block abbaue, kann ich daraus
verschiedene Gegenstände herstellen,
was unglaublich ist. Also, lass uns
tatsächlich etwas herstellen. Und um
ehrlich zu sein, wenn ich allein wäre
Was zum Oh, entschuldigt das, Leute.
Wie ich schon sagte, ich wollte nicht,
dass meine Ohren zerstört werden, aber
Claude Code hatte andere Pläne. Es hat
am Ende eine der verschiedenen Demos
gestartet, an denen ich eigentlich mit
Opus 5.5 gearbeitet habe. Es hat
willkürlich einen Server gestartet und
fing an, wahnsinnig laute Geräusche
abzuspielen, die meine Kopfhörer
völlig zerstört haben, aber jetzt
haben wir einen Zombie-Klon, den ich
gleich zeigen werde, aber zurück zu
unserer Demo. Hier in unserer Demo bin
ich gerade im Kreativmodus, aber schaut
euch nur an, wie gut es die
Texturierung all dieser verschiedenen
einzelnen Gegenstände hinbekommen hat.
Man hat sogar eine Spitzhacke. Wenn wir
nach unten gehen, zeige ich euch mal,
was es tatsächlich leisten konnte. Es
gibt verschiedene Erze. Es gibt sogar
verschiedene Höhlensysteme, die ich
gesehen habe. Das Einzige, was mir
bisher aufgefallen ist, ist, dass das
Beleuchtungssystem zwar funktioniert,
aber nicht so gut ist wie das, was ich
zuvor beim Fable-Modell gesehen habe,
aber egal, ich zeige euch jetzt die
Höhlensysteme. Leider glaube ich nicht
, dass es Höhlensysteme gibt, aber
insgesamt hat es einen wirklich
großartigen Sandbox-Klon des
ursprünglichen Minecraft-Spiels
erstellt. Leute, wie versprochen, hier
habe ich es gebeten, ein Call of Duty
Zombies-Spiel in 3D zu erstellen, und
schaut euch nur die Qualität an, Leute
. Das ist etwas, das ich noch bei
keinem KI-Modell gesehen habe. Die
Beleuchtung, die Textur, sogar alle
Attribute des ursprünglichen Spiels
wurden vollständig ausprogrammiert,
Leute. Das sieht man an einigen dieser
Animationen sowie daran, wie man
verschiedene Türen öffnen kann. Hier
kann man sogar verschiedene
Gegenstände kaufen, was man zwar auch
mit anderen Modellen hätte tun können
, aber nicht in dieser Qualität, Leute
. Das ist etwas, von dem ich nie
erwartet hätte, dass irgendein Modell
es tatsächlich generiert, Leute. Das
ist einfach wahnsinnig.
Sofortiger Kill.
Wir haben sogar diese
Barriere-Wiederaufbaufunktion, die
hinzugefügt wurde und die sogar eine
wirklich coole Animation hat.
Hilfe. Ich werde gerade eingekesselt.
Oh, Mist, Mann. Zimmermann. Mal sehen.
Jetzt kann ich einen weiteren Bereich
öffnen. Hier sehen Sie den Innenhof,
und er fügt viele coole verschiedene
Dinge hinzu, die ich von diesem Modell
wirklich nicht erwartet hätte, Leute.
Dies beinhaltet Beleuchtungen und
verschiedene Bereiche, in die man
hineinzoomen kann. Insgesamt bin ich
wirklich begeistert von der Qualität,
die dieses Modell erzeugt hat.
Wenn es um Front-End-Entwicklung geht,
glänzt das Modell besonders, und ich
glaube wirklich, dass es den ersten
Platz einnimmt. Es schlägt sich in
diesem speziellen Bereich bemerkenswert
gut. Es ist definitiv teuer, aber es
liefert die besten Ergebnisse basierend
auf der Beschreibung, die Sie ihm geben
. Hier ist ein weiterer Vergleich, der
den Sprung zeigt, denn Opus 5 kostete
bei dieser speziellen Erstellung einer
Vulkaninsel mit Dinosauriern etwa 1,60
$. Aber Opus 5.5 kostete etwa 3,40 $.
Das Ergebnis von Opus 5.5 war insgesamt
dramatisch reichhaltiger, mit einer
Unterwasser-Schnittszene, die ich so
bei keinem anderen Modell bisher
gesehen habe. Es gibt auch
Unterwasserwelt, wie man an dem Wal
sehen kann, der auf und ab springt. Man
hat Vegetation, Mammuts, Nordlichter
und viel mehr Details in der gesamten
Szene. Das habe ich bei allen
Generationen gesehen, und es zeigt
einfach, wie viel besser Opus 5.5 ist.
Und es sieht in vielen dieser
verschiedenen Fälle definitiv viel
besser aus als Astra. Wenn Ihnen dieses
Video gefällt und Sie den Kanal
unterstützen möchten, können Sie
über die „Super Thanks“-Option
unten eine Spende tätigen. Oder Sie
können unserem privaten Discord
beitreten, wo Sie monatlich kostenlosen
Zugriff auf mehrere Abonnements für
verschiedene KI-Tools erhalten. Dazu
gibt es tägliche KI-Nachrichten,
exklusive Inhalte und vieles mehr.
Insgesamt ist Opus 5.5 eine enorme
Verbesserung gegenüber den anderen
Opus 5-Modellen, und es sind nicht nur
die zusätzlichen Details, die es
besser machen. Es ist in der Lage,
insgesamt bessere Ergebnisse in
mehreren Bereichen zu erzielen. Ich
weiß, es verbraucht eine Menge Token,
aber es setzt neue Maßstäbe auf dem
aktuellen Stand der Technik. Dies ist
das beste Modell, das derzeit
verfügbar ist, und es bietet zudem
eine wirklich günstige Preisstruktur.
Sie haben also viele zusätzliche
Vorteile durch dieses Modell. Ich kann
nur empfehlen, es auszuprobieren, um zu
sehen, wie es funktioniert. Vielleicht
nicht für jede einzelne Aufgabe, da
man einfache Dinge natürlich an ein
billigeres Modell delegieren kann, aber
es wird Ihnen in vielen Bereichen
helfen, besonders wenn es darum geht,
komplexe Aufgaben zu erledigen. Ich
werde alle Links, die ich im heutigen
Video verwende, unten in die
Beschreibung setzen. Es würde mir
wirklich viel bedeuten, Leute, wenn ihr
euch die Welt der KI-Benchmarks und die
Vibe-Coding-Plattform ansehen könntet.
Schaut euch unbedingt auch unsere neue
School-Community an. Kommt zu unserem
zweiten Kanal. Abonniert den Newsletter
. Tretet dem Discord bei. Folgt mir auf
Twitter. Und zuletzt: Vergesst nicht,
den Kanal zu abonnieren, die Glocke zu
aktivieren, das Video zu liken und euch
unsere früheren Videos anzusehen,
damit ihr bei den neuesten KI-News auf
dem Laufenden bleibt. Aber mit diesem
Gedanken, Leute, habt einen
großartigen Tag. Verbreitet
Positivität und wir sehen uns schon
ganz bald wieder. Macht’s gut, Leute.